[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's another episode of chicken watch Oh
in the eye and we're ready to go eat
some fried chicken
today on chicken watch we are having
Indian fried chicken are there it's a
place called bod wash in downtown LA
turns on downtown la is a great chicken
spot chicken hub it's either your face
gets bright red or bright white here we
are
single white so we're at downtown LA and
our guest today is saucy tells me so so
I see in 10 seconds 10 seconds I produce
food videos and it's fun and I like
business and like 3 seconds under time
let's keep going
and I was like dad don't judge a book by
it's cover oh hi there welcome to
chicken watch right this way
oh hi there welcome to but my gosh come
on so here we do some traditional Indian
foods some not so traditional Indian
food we have fun with Indian flavors and
we invented the fried butter chicken
sandwich just what is butter chicken
it's basically butter maca and cream a
bunch of spices and it tastes amazing so
usually we go like what's the history of
this fried chicken but history is right
in this building we had to do a burger
pop-up and we had to come with that heat
everyone was making some beef burgers
some this burger some that burger and
we're like that should make a fried
chicken sandwich we took a big piece of
fried chicken dunked it in some butter
chicken sauce whoo
on some grocery store buns and hey maybe
some lettuce would be nice [ __ ] then we
ate it and is delicious
were you disqualified from the burger
now we won oh wow Wow we would I [ __ ]
the rules the chicken take one knuckle
how do we do this
starts with chicken thighs dark meat
nice and fatty it's been marinating for
48 hours and ginger garlic Serrano and
[Music]
then we just drop it in Laur shake it
off just give it a little shakey figure
and now egg wash I don't think we ever
talked enough about how the process of
fried chicken is to dip chicken in a
chicken product and then of seasoned
flour yeah he's got it two hands that's
called the double dragon where does
knuckle come from that call knuckle is
actually a mythological Hindu prints
from the Mahabharata the Great War whoa
wait says that your birth name yeah
knuckle is a cool name
sounds like a nickname I still haven't
found my sonic oh baby hey shake it off
a little bit then you want to sue [ __ ]
back and forth
yeah and now gently let go
so beautiful we pull it out we let it
cool and then we drop it in again looks
like nice and quiet it's like it's
whispering heat to you it's like it's
just going a little bit of a bedtime
story I'd say
[Music]
so Mogambo is the super villain in the
movie mr. India our favorite Indian
movie of all time he wears this crazy
like Michael Jackson outfit and he's got
this pool of lava that he opens up and
he like demands his people to jump in
the pool of lava to show their
allegiance to Mogambo and so us dropping
the chicken into this red saucy thing
it's kind of like us dropping the
chicken into the lobster oh and then
they'll say Mogambo cool
Mogambo is happy we've got some lettuce
here and that's just gonna sit right on
top yeah that's a chicken watch some
sweet cucumber pickles on top close it
drop a flag in it and I get a flag here
fried butter chicken salmon
yeah but mosh that was awesome
ticket why chicken watch I go on
alright let's try it oh wow hmm well
there's so many flavors untraditional
flavors uh-huh I like the soft stew
crunch like ASMR but not audio ASMR for
your mouth what's the spices that are
paprika cayenne pepper Indian rock salt
so black salt a little bit of kosher
salt pepper well it's a little enhanced
than the regular butter chicken it is
yeah this is really good but it doesn't
taste like a traditional fried chicken
sandwich it's kind of hard to wrap my
head around I would give it I've give it
a thumbs up would you yeah the pickles
honestly add to this for me cuz it's
like a whole new fling it's like a
sweetness to the salt and spice here's
my question yeah just I mean for the
Indian vegetarians out there do y'all
make like a paneer version of that or
well here's my answer
No
the whole essence of a fried chicken
sandwich is the fried chicken it's true
so I'm sorry you do not get paneer not
this time but if you want our butter
chicken sub paneer we can do that that's
what's confusing to me is it tastes like
Indian food and it tastes like fried
chicken
it's weird cuz it's kind of rich but I
was not like too full from that at all I
could eat 16 more how many sandwiches do
you think you sell a week let's so I
think it'd be even more popular if it
was on the menu but this is a secret
what do you mean it's a secret and it's
still super popular yes we're making a
video about it so someone else is gonna
know oh you're okay with that chicken
watch tell them chicken why they can
watch Delon chicken watch I'm already
upset because I'm half way through which
means it's almost over Oh Scott that's
the worst part of a fried chicken dinner
it's when you run out of fried chicken
you know it's almost over it's almost
over it's like being in the last chapter
of a book when everything's coming
together and it's nice but at the same
time you know it's almost over oh
there's a really good book there's a
really good book already wish it wasn't
over because he had such a good time
it's a little bit of a tragedy chicken
wash chicken wash chicken watch chicken
wash
[Music]
where are all the books
Oh chicken wash that sounds like a scary
I totally understand that people would
know about this even though it's a
secret menu item because this is the
kind of secret menu item that you could
tell people that this is your New York
Times bestseller list
yes call Oprah this is one for the books
so we have a fried chicken plate on our
menu served with a serrano cream okay so
this is a second fried chicken here we
haven't even talked about yeah you
talked about okay let's try the chicken
it's the same exact chicken
we just fry it and dust it with a little
bit of spice it's delicious
I love well a lot of flavor steam steam
test well I can see that steam you can
see the steam it steamed has nice this
is one of the most dynamic chickens
we've had in our search for the world
that's chicken I think I can I have more
[Music]
how much more can I have a lot more I'll
buy more to me this is interesting
because indeed people don't have Fried
Chicken it's always like butter chicken
tandoori chicken chicken tikka masala
but this just like changed it up I feel
like this on top of some pot sami rice
can be really good money right
nope Tommy rice that's time but Tommy
but time the time mario batali bus Tommy
what is it uh last morning last night
this is not just a silly show we're here
for a greater purpose yeah we're trying
to find the best fried chicken in the
world do you think that your fried
chicken sandwich well I guess this is
this is the season finale you're the
only confident chefs I've ever met do
you think this could become a trend I
think so I think this could be a thing
it's a really good thing so it should be
a thing it's really good it's really
good and I'm mad that I don't have any
more it's not some really well done
remember angle like the spices are
really good the frying itself is really
good the sauce and additions are really
good this might get a season wide wow
factor
yeah this is top wow this is one of the
top ways of the year yeah I think this
is an immediate contender of when people
come to visit me they have to come here
and have some fried chicken
Wow but MA
[Music]
it doesn't like the sheffster brothers
which is kind of fun
what we doing here today in tomorrow we
meet you with chicken brothers column
boils or mild coming at you oh yes you
breaking good no we breaking bad in this
neighborhood come on brothers you're
kind of like our sister kind up yeah
yeah yeah sister we just met today can
you try to pick it up with your
fingernail on food get a really good get
it I'm trying are you it's not happening
no here we go yeah males where's the
spork nailed it
chicken wash